maintenant un duo de choc al pacino
johnny depp dans un film intitulé donnie
brasco porter à l'écran l'histoire vraie
d'un agent du fbi haye qui s'était
introduit dans la mafia pour mieux la
combattre
cet homme existe vraiment même si depuis
il vit caché et a dû changer de visage
nicole cornu langois christophe airaud
je suis là c'est donner un ami à moi
c'est un copain sans grade qui
introduisit l'agent du fbi avec dans la
mafia tout je l'apprenne quoi un mec de
la mafia ils appellent tantôt feuilles
sont fait qu'il en fait un rouleau les
gros billets à l'extérieur
l'agente joue pistone dû prendre un nom
d'emprunt de libre asco et apprendre les
codes ce soit autre chose si je leur
disais c'est tania nous ça voudra dire
qu'il fait déjà partie lama faire
maintenant plus tard johnny depp est à
paris avec le vrai jo pistone qui depuis
qu'il a démantelé le plan dans lequel il
s'est infiltré doit vivre dans un
endroit secret a déménagé plusieurs fois
mais prend encore des risques en se
laissant surprendre à visage découvert
pour des photos ensemble johnston et
johnny depp ont construit le rôle de
donnie brasco
joppy sonne c'est un homme incroyable et
tellement obsédé tellement déterminé
pour accomplir sa mission à geste est
d'autant plus fascinée par sa
personnalité c'est un type très humain
très sensible avec plein d'émotions je
pense que c'est vraiment un type
intéressant c'est juste une grande
personne tu as touché parce que je me
porte garant pour toi je prends mal on
fait ce qu'on dit fait rentrer le fait
qu alors peut-être qu'un jour on ouvrira
le livre sur lequel tu sens inscrits a
franchi à la vie à la mort en chutant
poc toutes leurs conversations sont
enregistrées par le fbi john pistole
trahi son ami aujourd'hui il préfère
répondre à visage caché pas de romans je
n'ai pas l'impression de l'avoir trahi
devez comprendre que j'étais un agent du
fbi et que c'était mon travail je devais
arrêter ces gangsters et les mettre en
prison car exchanger il en fit tuer
quelques uns aussi et les rapports
conjugaux furent plutôt perturbé par
cette double vie qui durera six ans la
brillante interprétation de al pacino et
johnny depp donne à cette histoire vraie
une dimension tragique évident tu repars
témoin et c'est ton meilleur ami qui
claquent
le pacifique